Let's work on forming the /ʃ/ sound.
Let your jaw release slightly so your lips are parted.
Bring the blade of your tongue up to the roof of your mouth...
...and push the air out around the sides of the tongue.
Let your hand touch your throat,...
...make sure you don't feel any vibration.
/ʃ/, /ʃ/, /ʃ/.
Here's /ʃ/ in the beginning of some words.
Ship, Shape, Shower.
Here it is in the middle.
Pushing, Fishing, Smashes.
And here is /ʃ/ at the end of some words.
Bash, Fish, Dish.
Listen to these pairs of words to hear the contrasting sounds.
Ship, Chip.
Ship, Sip.
Cash, Catch.
Mash, Mass.
And here are some sentences that use the /ʃ/ sound.
The fish dish on the ship was smashing!
She paid cash for the shower cap.
/ʃ/, /ʃ/, /ʃ/.
Great job!